hey
uh
is running out
the prophecies say final winter leads to
ragnarok
war is coming
my story doesn't end hiding in these
woods
i should be out there finding out who i
am who loki is
i will not allow you to pick a fight
with god
i don't want to fight anyone
i just want answers
and if those answers lead to war with
asgard
maybe that's what mother won
you do not know what mother watching
well
i don't recognize that double expression
anywhere
odin's got tricks up his sleeve we
haven't dared to consider
what if there was someone who could help
us
you mean tyr
the old god of war in these lands who is
dead
well for a dead man odin seemed pretty
keen on seeing he wasn't found
if he's out there
we gotta find him
come in
what in all yards be the happened to him
we're trying to stop ragnarok to help
people and what if the only way to do
that is war
war is not the only way
stop thinking like a father for a moment
and start thinking like a general
you seem like a calm and reasonable
person
are you a calm and reasonable person
[Music]
in moments of crisis
panic does nothing
harness it
[Music]
let it serve you
here
are you coming with us
you'll get your answer soon enough
well some of them